hi guys in this video I'm going to talk
about the best remedy to repair liver
damage after alcohol but not just
alcohol drugs medication prescription
acetaminophen which is tylenol aspirin
which all damaged liver in the
gallbladder and it creates cirrhosis a
fatty liver inflammation and just make
the liver toxic okay the best herb to do
that would be milk thistle let me
explain why this herb is one of the most
thoroughly studied scientifically proven
powerful natural remedies to reverse
damage to your liver cells okay and the
gall bladder which is amazing so it's
been around for a long time I'll put
some links down below but it can do a
lot of things it reduces inflammation
it's good for other things like the
kidney but mainly what it can do it can
reverse damage to your liver the active
ingredient is called silly Marion and
and also increases glutathione which is
another powerful antioxidant to repair
damage on the liver as well and the
gallbladder for example so again for
short-term quick fix this is what you
want long-term you're going to have to
do you have to change your diet you're
going to have to consume a lot of
cruciferous vegetables that are high in
the sulfur mineral and choline to
actually repair liver liver as well so
go ahead and try it and put your
comments down below hey you probably
already subscribed but if you haven't
press this little button down below and
I will keep you updated